uh dealershaw I don't know that guy
shouldn't be allowed to fight he [ __ ]
he should be banned forever TJ Dillashaw
versus Al Jermaine Sterling another
fantastic fight the bandweight division
and this fight is all about getting
respect for aljame Sterling despite the
fact that he got the title the way he
did and then went and got the title the
way that we all wanted him to in the
first place there's still this little
tinge of yeah but Izzy and I'm telling
you if he can go out there and take out
TJ Dillashaw who we all know what TJ is
capable of if he can go out there and
have a performance against TJ Dillashaw
I feel like that respect is going to be
earned and we got to shut up all of us
whether it's the fans the media whoever
have to give algeman the respect that he
is due however if T.J Dillashaw can come
back and be the TJ that we know he's
capable capable of being
absolutely TJ dilshaw has the skills
that are necessary to be a UFC champion
once again
[Music]